okay so that's me that's me doing what I
do best what I love doing which is
presenting and just a little bit about
me I've been doing exam prep coaching
for 14 years I've had over 5000 people
go through classes my classes range from
a SMP and PPO my ACP and the PMI RMP and
those are the credentials that I have
those are the classes that I teach and I
know we're here about the ASM I've been
doing project management in one form or
another for a very long time either in
the business sector or private sector or
as an entrepreneur for example I work
for Compaq and HP is a project manager I
was vice president of a company in
Southern California I was the executive
director of the California Commission on
the bicentennial celebration of the
United States Constitution some other
things those are just a highlight so 35
years it seems like regardless of what
the job was I was developing content
being a presenter or a trainer now I'll
mention this again a little bit later
but there's a difference between how
much money we make if we're certified it
compared to those that are uncertified
so in depending on studies I've seen
several it's 15 percent the twenty
percent more than your uncertified
colleagues so I figure based on those
that have been through my classes and
gotten certified collectively they're
making more than sixty million dollars a
year than they used to and I've been
with simply learned now for three years
absolutely love it simply learn is a
first-class organization
it's the largest training organization
in the world recently it was new
is one of the top 10 most influential
education companies in the world let's
just kind of get our heads into the game
here and let's just talk briefly about
project management not that you don't
know this but this kind of gets us going
and helps us get onto the same page so I
view project management as the science
of getting stuff done and everybody
needs to get stuff done and you know
humanities needed to do stuff
you know for a very long time and if we
think about the pyramids in Egypt the
Roman aqueducts cathedrals in Europe the
first transcontinental railway in
America all of these are examples of
projects and so there's always been some
kind of project management going on it
was informal and didn't begin to emerge
as a profession until the mid 20th
century and in fact prior to the 1950s
projects were just managed on an ad-hoc
basis maybe using Gantt charts or
informal techniques and tools but in the
1950s that's the real beginning of
modern project management where core
engineering fields came together to work
as one and so you know just you know
definitionally a project is a temporary
endeavor that results in something
unique meaning it's not part of our
routine day to day operations
developing a software application
constructing a building expanding sales
into a new market and conducting a
research effort are all examples of
projects and as I'm sure you all know
they need to be expertly managed in
order to deliver the value the customer
wants on-time and on-budget as I'm sure
you are aware there are two basic
approaches to project management
there's waterfall and agile and at a
high level the differences are that the
waterfall approach or the plan driven
approach favors projects with clear
requirements
the creation of a master plan upfront
and then measuring actual results - the
plan is the projects being executed on
in order to determine the health of the
project the agile approach focuses on
projects with unclear or changing
requirements and delivering value to the
customer and frequent short iterations
agile evolved in the 1990s in response
to three main issues these are problems
that software developers had in using
the traditional waterfall approach when
it came to project projects for
developing software one is the heavy
burden of documentation documentation in
the sense of upfront requirements a big
master plan status reports
you know details like that frequent
requirement changes and poor quality
software an agile is a family of methods
and we're going to talk more about scrum
today than any of the others but from a
generic point of view one of the agile
thought leader Scott Ambler described
agile this way agile is an iterative and
incremental evolutionary approach to
project development which is performed
by a highly in a highly collaborative
manner by self-organizing teams with
just enough ceremony that produces
high-quality software in a
cost-effective and timely manner which
meets the changing needs of its
stakeholders I got a question here does
project management belong to operations
no that's a good question so operations
are those ongoing things those routine
things that a business needs to do on a
daily basis to keep the business going
projects are efforts that result in
something unique in order to advance the
strategic direction of the company like
make money for example or reduce the
cost of operations so well you might use
some project management
this is to do operations operations
themselves are not projects and would
not benefit from using all of the
practices that we use in project
management now the team I was going to
use my whiteboard and talk about the
triple constraint and the agile
triangles and if you can picture a
triangle in your mind one side of scope
and other side is schedule and the other
side is cost and the triple constraint
triangle is used to describe what a
project managers responsibilities are
and it goes something like this your job
as a project manager is to balance the
competing demands of scope schedule and
cost while maintaining a high level of
quality
now the agile triangle which is actually
invention of a guy named Jim Highsmith
another one of our agile thought leaders
said actually because agile is different
than the waterfall approach we can take
that triangle and look at the three
corners of the triangle so picture a
triangle and at the bottom right corner
that would be labeled the triple
constraint meaning scope schedule and
class so even an agile we have to deal
with scope schedule and cost we don't
get away from that although those are
managed differently in agile than they
are in waterfall and then over on the
bottom left corner that would be
intrinsic quality so intrinsic quality
is from the team's point of view this is
addressing the correctness of the code
that's being written is it's being
tested unit tests etc and so that has to
do with the verification or the
correctness of the code it's the team
view it's the intrinsic quality and it
also includes how the project is being
run is it being run well are we using
the scrum practices
and techniques as we're supposed to and
then at the top of the triangle that
corner there is the extrinsic quality
and that's the customer's point of view
so that's acceptance and there are tests
associated with acceptance as well and
so that's the validation that's the
acceptance that's the customer point of
view and so the agile triangle reflects
the emphasis that agile puts on
delivering high quality software
recognizing that you have to focus on
both the intrinsic side as well as the
extrinsic side in order to have an
acceptable quality outcome now when it
comes to agile versus waterfall for
software projects I've got a graphic
right here that shows that waterfall
versus agile is vastly different when it
comes to the results notice looking on
the left hand side 29% of waterfall
projects software development projects
fail in agile only 9% now there's still
you know a high level of you know
challenge that's a part of it but notice
that 14% success versus 42% success so
the reason that you're one of the
reasons you're probably on this webinar
right here is because something's going
on in your world that is making you
interested in agile and scrum in
particular and this is why because
organizations that have been using the
traditional approach are recognizing at
least when it comes to software projects
that agile is a much better approach and
I've got a little bit of a summary chart
right here that focuses on some of the
key differences between the traditional
approach and the agile approach looking
at planning in waterfall the emphasis is
on upfront planning in agile it's on
ongoing planning back the waterfall
detailed requirements are defined
upfront prior to starting and
then in agile we only use a high-level
product o'clock up front and then defer
planning decisions as long as possible
when it comes to communications and this
speaks to documentation its formal and
structured versus an agile it's people
oriented with informal but constant
communication and then when it comes to
project ceremonies and those are like
meetings events things like that in
waterfall there's a high degree of
project ceremony team meetings formal
project reviews document of status
reports etc in agile it's low it's low
project ceremony few team meetings brief
project reviews and document status
reports that are just a high level when
it comes to measuring progress in
waterfall that is demonstrated by
artifacts and milestones in agile it's
demonstrated by working software you
know that is delivered to the customer
and then when it comes to change
Waterfall has formal change control
procedures and in agile there's limited
or no formal change control and back in
waterfall scope control is essential in
order to control cost and schedule and
an agile scope is expected to change and
expand in order to meet the customers
needs because we've been talking about
these two approaches I don't want
anybody to get the opinion that you know
all projects should be done using agile
that's not the case
Waterfall works there's a reason why you
know lots of people want to go out and
get either their PMP or their prince2
certifications for example it's because
the traditional more structured approach
works and so here's a spectrum that kind
of shows you where the sweet spot for
agile is in kind of the pinkish color
there the simple and complicated boxes
represent those projects that are
probably best used by
but would best benefit from using the
waterfall approach and then in the green
area that's the sweet spot for agile so
that's where there's a high level of
complexity and uncertainty that's when
you want to approach it using the agile
one of the agile methods there's also an
area that we just call anarchy or chaos
that's where there's really nothing
that's organized not yet to use some
kind of formal approach and the chaos or
the anarchy would need to be resolved
and moved into either agile or into the
waterfall segments here in order to
really be managed let's see I got a
question here PMP is mostly based on
waterfall where CSM is on agile as
having both certifications make sense so
that's a question from Prashant and it
makes sense to me in fact here's what I
believe this is what I see going on the
most valuable and effective project
managers of the future you know going
forward will be those that are certified
in both waterfall and agile some kind of
agile certification I you know you know
I have certifications in both and it has
helped me in both running waterfall
projects and running agile projects and
in fact most projects are going to be
run in some kind of a hybrid format and
so if I'm hiring somebody that I want to
be on a team for a project of mine I
would want to see something like the ASM
and the PMP if I saw that I think okay
that person is got the skills the
knowledge the experience that I need
that you mentioned the CSM now that's a
certified scrum master that is a little
bit different than the ASM and I'll get
into some of the differences in in just
a little bit the the CSM is a relatively
lightweight certification it's very
popular but
it's an open book you know you go to a
training open book done you know
basically if you're breathing you can
get it there's no experience or training
needed the ASM requires some training
and so if an employer is looking at the
ASM you know employer is going to say
okay I know this person had to go
through some training in order to be
able to get that certification but
either way the point of the question is
you know waterfall versus agile and my
answer is you got to have certifications
in both ASM stands for agile scrum
master um ed PSM helped me out with that
what's PSM professional scrum master is
that what that one is yeah okay I'm not
as familiar with that one so I probably
can't comment on it that might be a more
intense version that is offered by the
scrum Alliance and maybe you know better
than I do on that okay so now in fact
that question was actually a great segue
into this because I think that it's
worth noting that while there's probably
more people that have started with the
waterfall certification and are now
looking at agile and the other way
around as I was just mentioning I think
successful project managers are going to
need to be certified in both so getting
your ASM so again that's the eggs in ASM
agile scrum master credential also
increases your earning potential and
this is what I was talking about when I
was introducing myself a little bit and
you know there are entities that do
these surveys you know for different
types of careers and depending on the
year it fluctuates a little bit but
generally speaking certified project
managers are going to earn fifteen to
twenty percent more than their non
certified peers and also in most of
those studies it indicates a steeper
trajectory for your career so we all
know that you know certifications count
for something in the world
we may not love standardized testing and
kind of think it's a lousy way to
measure someone's real-world potential
and I sort of agree with that but you
know what it doesn't really change
anything because people want to see
certifications and so you use a company
like eggs in and simply learn people
know that that means it's legitimate
that it means something you know a
person will still have to prove
themselves in the real world but you
know that's a great place to start let's
see I'm just looking at the chat box
over here
oh that's by the scrum organization oh
so that's the competing one yeah yeah
know a little bit about that a guy named
Mike Cohen who's a big scrum guy he
started the scrum Alliance there are
some problems he withdrew he started
another one so there's a little bit of
mix-up over there but you know the
reason that we're even talking about
scrum and whether you know it's ASM or
other certifications that have to do
with scrum it's because scrum is the
leading agile method you know there's a
bunch of methods that belong to the
family of agile there's from there's XP
there's crystal there's Kanban there's
dsdm APM fdv there's a whole bunch that
all fit under this umbrella of agile but
of all agile projects more than 50% end
up using scrum so the reason that scrum
is so popular is because it emphasizes
small empower teams and we need a chat
about that in just a minute because
actually you can you can scale scrum now
there's some standards for that so that
you can actually do very large projects
still using the scrum approach but scrum
is you know it embraces changing
requirements which is very attractive to
the customer and the business interest
in an organization potentially shippable
font software is the output of each
friend and if Sprint is a new term to
you that's just the label for a short
iteration or increment that the team it
engages in in order to develop software
and when I say short in scrum it's two
to four weeks in duration so at the end
of every two weeks or three weeks
whatever it is the customer gets working
software now the the customer email may
not want to release it yet but if it is
releasable and the customer wants to
release it the customer could do that
right away and even get some return on
investment so in in my real world I have
a project that I'm working on and it's a
website and our product roadmap calls
for three different versions but when we
release version one which is going to be
free - everybody's going to have a tool
that people can access if they want and
use it for free but we're also going to
include the ability to do some banner
ads and other things like that so even
before we start working on version 2
we'll have some revenue coming in and
then version 2 includes a you know
additional tools and a subscription
ability so that will have its own return
on investment built into it and then
version 3 adds additional tools and the
opportunity for people to earn a
commission if they refer somebody but
for that kind of a project that I'm just
describing waterfall would be very
difficult to use but using scrum it'll
work great and and I'm sure some of you
have already experienced that as well so
you know what I'm talking about if you
haven't and you're new to agile and
you're new to scrum just understand the
developers and customers once they
understand it they love it not just
because of the proven results but
because of the the collaborative working
together relationship
results in value early and often so it's
that's why it's so popular I thought you
might be interested especially those of
us that are kind of new to scrum this is
an overview of what a project lifecycle
looks like for scrum if you look over
here on the left there's what's called
the product backlog and each item in the
project backlog is some kind of feature
or function the customer wants to be
developed and so the product backlog
really defines the scope of the project
and items can be added or removed at any
time we embrace change we love it so the
customer thinks of something new or
wants to make a change all the customer
does is you know what the product owner
just change the product backlog and then
what the team will do is they will
create a sprint which will include a
number of items pulled from the product
backlog the top priority items and maybe
there'll be two or three or four
depending on the size of the items that
will be included in a sprint and as I
said a sprint can be two to four weeks
in this example here we're showing four
weeks and also while the Sprint is
underway there's a 24-hour cycle where
the team starts the day with what we
call the daily scrum which is a short
time box 15-minute meeting that allows
the developers to coordinate their
efforts and then at the end of the
sprint there's some working software
that's been developed than it is
showcased for the product owner and the
customer the end user others that might
be interested in it and during that
review the software is demoed and then
the product owner says yes I accept it
or I reject it and then the process
starts over again and the team does
another sprint and this is all done with
the RO
Tivoli small-sized team the rule of
thumb is six plus or minus three so
typically three to nine individuals are
on the team let's see I got a question
here what's the difference between
software and incremental release
practice and agile I would say it's
probably the same thing so agile
releases software in increments so you
know going back to the description of
agile right here it is an iterative and
incremental evolutionary approach to
project development so did that answer
your question okay
does that make sense okay good thank you
for that feedback okay so we talked
about the scrum lifecycle a bit now
let's talk a little bit more about why
you're actually here and the ASM
workshop that simply learn offers so you
cannot actually sit for the ASM exam
unless you have completed successfully
some training and so what we offer it
simply learn is kind of a combined thing
where you get the training that meets
the requirement to sit for the exam as
well as treating it as an exam prep
workshop as well as somebody's pointing
out here I have a point to make
regarding the previous question and that
is scrum is accelerated agile possibly
having small sprints right in in scrum
the iterations are going to be two to
four weeks in length if we were to look
at the overall family of agile it would
be a little bit different it would be
will be one to six weeks in duration
there are a few that are shorter than a
week and a few that are longer but the
vast majority of all agile projects will
use iterations or sprints that will be
one to six weeks in duration and in
scrum specifically to the four we
so that was good thank you what's the
difference between scrum and agile scrum
there's no difference it's just it's a
different certification and and I'll
cover the differences here because I
think you will find the ASM to be very
attractive and it's relatively new
but it is emerging in fact I just got a
call from my colleagues have simply
learned today where there's a company a
global company that wants to put a
number of people through our workshop so
they can get their ASM certifications
and they were just finding out when I
could do that in-house class for them so
what we cover in the workshop will be
you know key concepts of agile we're
going to cover the basic stuff as all of
the others do but we will then focus on
scrum specifically and so the course
also has breakout sessions and some
games kind of some hands-on engagement
so that when you're finished even if you
even before you actually pass the exam
you can start applying the things that
you've learned in your real-life
experience you'll learn specifically how
scrum adds value to the development and
delivery of high-quality software in the
course we're going to cover roles
ceremonies artifacts that define and
constitute scrum methodology as well as
best practices for actually getting the
maximum value from the scrum method so
who's gonna benefit from this you know
anybody that's looking to update their
knowledge of software development
project management is going to benefit
from this course and as a project
management professional you derive value
in multiple ways for example you'll
learn the best practices for scrum and
some of the other agile methods you'll
get deep insight into scrum and discover
new ways of leading project management
teams and delivering value to customers
you're going to get practical guidance
on how to implement the practices
maximize their value and then it also
positions you very well to become an
evangelist or a champion in the agile
adoption journey that your organization
might be engaged in or contemplating
let's see another question here um Jeff
among agile scrum scaled agile and
disciplined agile which one is the the
futuristic most futuristic and important
so in my opinion I would actually pick
two and add something to your question
there so I think you know agile scrum
you got to have that but then scaled
agile so the baseline would be agile
scrum and you wouldn't in my view you
wouldn't do anything beyond that until
you had that down and then scaled agile
is the next one and knowing how to take
a method that was originally designed
for small projects and small teams and
use that approach in order to do an
enterprise size project that's where the
biggest I think return on investment is
for us as practitioners is scaled agile
and then I would add to that being able
to link our development efforts with
operations
it's called DevOps and also being able
to link our efforts with service
management and those are things that are
covered in the ASM exam and in the
training that's not included anywhere
else at least as far as I know so just
another slide focusing on you know the
value of the
you're gonna understand good practices
that are used in different agile methods
you're going to understand how the
concepts can be implemented in your real
world you'll have a thorough knowledge
of scrum when you're finished and here's
something that I was just mentioning
that's a little bit unique and that is
you'll be able to lead the agile
transformation in your organization one
of our lessons is actually on agile
adoption and another one is on one whole
lesson is on scaling agile and then of
course comprehension you're going to
learn new things different practices
tools and techniques and how to derive
value from those practices so probably
what the next thing to do right now
would be to just give you a brief
overview of what the course agenda is
see if it fits in to what you need and
I'll keep my eye on the question box
over here in case you have any questions
but lesson one is about agile you know
generically and so we'll talk about what
it is we'll get into the agile manifesto
if you're in one of my classes I'm also
going to take you into the twelve
guiding principles behind it and then
we're going to touch on a scrum a little
bit and we're going to also touch on
scrum adoption agile adoption and then
when we get into lesson two we're going
to chat just a little bit about
Waterfall kind of like we did here and
then we're going to actually review some
of the other agile methods like XP and
Crystal and lean and dsdm that's the
same as a turn by the way and we're
going to talk about DevOps which I was
just mentioning in response to that one
question as well as agile and IT Service
Management and it looks like I got some
action
here in the question box so let me see
here
does the ASM course cover both scrum and
scaled agile yes it does another
question here does ASM cover taking
different statistics for a sprint we're
taking different statistics for a sprint
you.they and I'm not exactly sure how to
pronounce your name I apologize I'm not
quite sure what you mean could you try
and rephrase that for me give me a
little assist there and while you're
doing that Kanban and lean are the same
framework actually they're not there is
Kanban there is lean and there's also
lean Kanban and if you want I could
teach you about all three of those we're
not going through we'll get into some of
it a little bit but we're going to spend
most of our time when it gets down into
the details on scrum because again
that's the most popular one and that's
probably even why you're here right you
have some reason to want to know more
about scrum and get certified as a scrum
master let's see like calculating
estimated versus actual oh yeah so the
question is I guess about sprint
planning so yes we're going to talk
about the two most popular estimating
methods we'll do planning poker will do
affinity estimating and we will spend a
fair amount of time on the Sprint
retrospective which is where we do you
know problem detection and resolution
and work on continuous improvement so
did that get you there today is that
what you were asking
and again I apologize if I'm not
pronouncing your name quite right okay
yes thank you perfect thanks when we get
to lesson three this is when we start
getting into agile specifically there's
going to be the five values of scrum
we're going to cover those we'll go over
the scrum lifecycle will have a screen
similar to the one that I showed you but
we'll go into it in much more detail
hovering sprint planning the sprint
itself the daily scrums the sprint
review the sprint retrospective we'll
talk about the concept of time boxing
and why that's critical for scrum to be
successful and we'll also go over key
artifacts that are a part of scrum
product backlog sprint backlog release
backlog definition have done we'll get
into some of the information radiators
that are used to display progress while
the while Sprint's are underway with
then we're going to in Lesson number
four we're going to cover the three
roles that are a part of scrum there's
the scrum master the product owner and
the team our mode most of the emphasis
in Lesson four will be on the scrum
master side and but we will also cover
the roles and the duties of the product
owner and the team members as we go
through the course we're going to we're
also going to you know do a breakout and
we're going to do a practice daily scrum
we're going to do a practice planning
poker session we'll probably also do a
release planning session just so that
you knows we're going over some of these
concepts will just say okay now let's
take a break here and now let's just
practice doing one of these together so
well it's also exam prep and I'm when we
go through the course we're also going
to tell you the things that we want you
to memorize before you sit for the exam
so we'll be approaching it from you know
how do you pass the exam as well as you
know how do you become a good certified
scrum master lesson 5 is about agile
estimating and planning we're going to
talk about the differences between
themes epic stories tasks we're going to
talk about the different levels of
planning as I mentioned we'll get into
planning poker an affinity estimating
we'll talk about the difference between
s
the mating using points as opposed to
ideal time in lesson six this is the one
that focuses on scaling agile so we'll
talk about that and we'll talk about
agile in a distributed environment you
know where you have virtual teams which
it just seems like in everybody's world
you know even though you know scrum
favors face-to-face co-located teams you
know technology has advanced and needs
of advanced and the world's just gotten
smaller so if you haven't you're gonna
be in a virtual environment at some
point in time you know and I've been
involved with projects where I had team
members in the Philippines Costa Rica
and different places in the United
States and you know using technology you
can almost make it a face-to-face team
room experience so we'll talk about that
a bit while we're going through lesson
six as well and then lesson seven is one
that I absolutely love this is the one
that has to do with adopting agile and
lesson six and seven are are unique to
ASM and you know to me it adds so much
more value to your certification as a
scrum master because it's not just how
do you do a scrum master for a small
team but you get how to you know be a
lead in a much larger project where you
might have you know multiple scrum teams
that need to be coordinating together
etc and then also you know adopting
agile in every one of the ASM workshops
I've done I've had people who were in
the class either because they were in
the middle of an adoption effort or
their company was about to embark on it
and so we get into it we we even talk
about the types of complaints you're
likely to get how to overcome them we
talk about the resistance that you'll
likely get you know and we talk about it
in terms of being you know diehards
followers skeptics and saboteurs and we
talk about how to overcome that
resistance you know what you actually do
you know and we even talk about
strategies you know is it going to be
all in are you gonna start small you
know are you gonna split and grow are
you going to grow and see split and seed
so we get into all of that we even talk
about the HR department which has to you
know modify its approach when it comes
to you know the organization and the
different roles the different
responsibilities reporting is different
in agile you know you don't have the
same kind of individual focus and
reviews because everything is focused on
the team today when we get into all of
that when it comes to the test itself
which of course is how we memorialize
our efforts is to actually pass the exam
you know we say here that it probably
takes about 120 hours of study to get
ready you know maybe less depending on
your exposure but you know what I have
been noticing that based on our workshop
that's you know the training / exam prep
we're getting it done with just that
even people who have been brand-new to
agile and scrum they're going and
they're passing their ASM exam by doing
our workshop so that 120 hours is
probably in an overestimation at least
if you're going to use simply learn
because we've got it nailed we know
exactly what you need we talked about
the you know some of the activities case
studies etc that are part of the
training which is mandatory before you
can actually write the exam now the exam
itself get this it's a 90 minute exam
and there's only 40 questions but you
know what it it's not easy to pass now
let me say that differently
the questions are hard and you got to
think about them but if you've been
through our workshop and you've
memorized what I asked you to memorize
and you've done you know you know
acquired the knowledge that you get by
going through those seven lessons you'll
get it done
I used this course itself
for my own training and exam prep and I
passed first time I didn't get a hundred
percent now maybe that will discourage
you I got 80 percent passing is 65
percent so it seems like it'd be easy to
pass but you know it in if you have not
gone through the training you will pass
there's not a chance in the world you'll
pass it you go through the training yeah
you'll pass you'll get your ASM and then
as I mentioned the course itself
actually meets the training requirement
that you have to submit to or verify
with eggs in before you can write the
exam you think haiti's too good now you
know what's funny is you know it's
broken up into some domains and one of
the domains I got a hundred percent so
every question honor the guy 100 percent
and that was adopting agile and I told
you I liked that lesson the best out of
all of them and so that kind of reflects
on my exam performance the area that I
did the worst in I still was passing in
that area was the actual scrum master
part and that was because I have such a
strong background in waterfall that I
struggled with some of the scenario
questions so I'll be able to help you
out with that when we go through the
workshop to make sure that you really
you can't see me and I'm making all
these hand gestures here to make my
points and emphasize them but in order
to pass the exam you have to
successfully make the switch from
thinking waterfall to thinkin scrum
when you get that done then it becomes a
lot easier but you know for me and I've
been at this a long time it was still a
bit of a struggle so any way I can help
coach you through that as well how does
the ASM compared with the pmi-acp that's
a good question and I can speak to that
because I have them both they are there
are some similarities you know a as the
ACP it's a little bit more in-depth into
the different methods of agile for that
you know we're gonna drill down you know
I think we're going to go over eight or
nine of the methods and and then it's
more about agile from a generic point of
view so we talked about scrum and we get
into it but it's agile from a generic
point of view so the ASM is got some of
the agile basics right the core stuff
that you need to understand generically
but then the rest of the focus is on ASM
or pardon me is on scrum I I don't
actually think that they're the well
there's some similarities I actually see
value in both by the way I love the ASM
because of the emphasis on the scrum
master so if you're going to be in a
scrum environment you would do better
starting with your ASM and then if you
had a desire to know more about agile in
general than the pmi-acp would be a good
follow-up choice so the acp that stands
for a credit let's see agile certified
practitioner and that's offered by PMI
which is the same one that does the PMP
so to kind of circle back to one of the
questions that we had earlier if you
have your PMP go get your ASM after have
your PMP in your ASM then you can start
thinking about getting some more
certifications that might flesh out your
experience and resume a bit what is the
cost of the training course and the
certifications I don't know and I had
sent an email before class and I was
hoping to get an answer back on that I'm
not involved in the sales at all so
maybe they don't want me to know how
much it cost but my understanding is is
that the the cost of the ASM course also
includes the cost of the exam
so whatever it is it's an
all-encompassing one so Deepak and
others that you know are going to be
interested in doing the ASM class you're
going to have to get online and you're
going to have to go ahead and go through
that process and find it out there and
you can tell i'm very american in my
pronunciation of some of your names and
i am working on that and i'm actually
I've got a pending trip to India coming
up to actually go to simply learns
headquarters and meet some of the people
that I work with on the phone and
virtually all day every day and I'm
hoping while I'm there I can get some
more coaching on how to actually
pronounce names so please don't take it
personally I am working on it and I'm
better than I was but I know I'm not
there yet okay so that's some
information about the exam itself so
awesome team thank you for your
interaction your feedback your questions
you all certainly helped contribute to
the value of this endeavor and with that
I will say goodbye and I look forward to
crossing paths with you in the future
you